Donald Trump once again has asserted
that massive voter fraud was the reason
why he lost the popular vote to Hillary
Clinton in the 2016 election this dates
back to 2016 Trump has been asserting
the elections rigged he didn't win the
popular vote because 325 million
undocumented immigrants voted people
also registered twice like his own
daughter and Steve benen and other
people associated with him and he said
he would launch an investigation into
the matter again in spite of there being
no evidence to suggest that this is true
in his first meeting in January with
lawmakers after being inaugurated as
president of the United States Donald
Trump brought it up again and some of
the lawmakers in the room found it a
little odd and then just a few days ago
at a meeting with ten senators Donald
Trump again brought up this debunked
conspiracy theory about 325 million
undocumented immigrant voters the
meeting was supposed to be an effort for
the White House to gain bipartisan
support for Trump's Supreme Court
nominee Neil Gorsuch and Donald Trump
opted to go completely off the rails
went on a rant about voter fraud of
course despite the fact that he won the
presidency continues to talk about it
former this is where it gets really
weird former New Hampshire senator Kelly
Ayotte was in the meeting and she lost
her re-election campaign in November and
Trump at the meeting said Oh both Kelly
Ayotte and I would have won New
Hampshire if it hadn't been for
thousands of people who were brought in
on buses from Massachusetts to vote
illegally in New Hampshire no evidence
for this and one person present present
at the meeting said that that was
followed by what they described as an
uncomfortable silence in the room
because obviously it's all completely
made up and then our new buddy who
channeled Kim jong-un on the Sunday
morning shows over the weekend Trump's
adviser Trump's senior adviser who is 31
years old Stephen Miller backed it up on
ABC News here's what that looked like
I've actually having worked before on
a campaign in New Hampshire I can tell
you this issue of bussing voters into
New Hampshire is widely known by anyone
who's worked in New Hampshire politic
it's very real it's very serious this
morning on this show is not the venue
for me to lay out all the evidence the
president made a statement saying he was
the victim of voter fraud can be less
the president's the Mayor was do you
have any at issue if this is an issue
that interests you that we can talk
about it more in the future yeah when
Stephen Miller says it's okay to talk
about the the president of blatant lies
you'll be allowed to talk about them
wouldn't we have heard about this if it
was actually a widely known phenomenon
from some source other than the
conspiratorial recesses of the internet
and Donald Trump who happens to be
President of the United States it's
possible Pat it crossed my mind maybe
it's Stephen Miller who planted this
idea originally in Donald Trump's head
because he's the guy who's saying oh
it's absolutely true without actually
citing any evidence for it right and
what Stephen Miller said there was just
horribly unconvincing I mean he says
that he doesn't have enough time to lay
out all of the evidence on a show but
could you just name one piece of
evidence or maybe go back later and put
it in the transcript or something you
know like digit on the same damn thing
here's another really just bizarre thing
and this goes to the idea that just none
of this makes any sense Kelly Ayotte had
denounced Trump in 2016 and during this
meeting that took place Donald Trump
told Kelly Ayotte he wished that she had
campaigned for him and added you'd have
one in New Hampshire if you had been on
my train that doesn't make any sense
Trump first said that Kelly Ayotte lost
because of voter fraud thousands of
people going on buses from Massachusetts
to New Hampshire to vote against her and
vote against Trump but then Trump later
in the meeting says actually you lost
because you didn't support me so which
is it but again in the bizarro land of
Trump conspiracy theories it doesn't
matter that trumps two ideas are
completely self contradictory also from
this meeting senator said that Donald
Trump refer to Elizabeth Warren as
pocahontas again which is one of his
favorite lines from his campaign
this is the president of the United
States at a meeting with senators
referring to another senator as
pocahontas it is off the rails folks
embarrassingly so